[Música]
un momento marcado por la tradición y el
simbolismo por primera vez el rey carlos
tercero entró al westminster hall como
monarca durante 900 años el palacio de
westminster ha visto pasar a los reyes y
reinas en el trono este lunes fue el
turno del nuevo rey del reino unido- de
presenciar una audiencia repleta de
caras conocidas mientras los miembros de
la cámara de los comunes y de la cámara
de los lores le ofrecieron sus
condolencias los presidentes de ambas
cámaras fueron los primeros en tomar la
palabra rindiendo homenaje a la reina
a pesar de que nuestro dolor es profundo
sabemos que el suyo lo es más le
brindamos nuestro sincero apoyo a usted
ya toda la familia real
en su discurso el rey reconoció la
responsabilidad que ahora pesa sobre sus
espaldas
estoy profundamente agradecido por las
condolencias expresadas por la cámara de
los comunes y de los lores mientras me
dirijo a ustedes hoy no puedo evitar
sentir el peso de la historia a nuestro
alrededor
el rey carlos también recordó a su
audiencia la dedicación de su madre a la
defensa de los principios
constitucionales
chipsets a nixon of south siento un
ejemplo de deber abnegado que con la
ayuda de dios y sus consejos estoy
decidido a seguir fielmente el show
tras sus palabras ante el parlamento el
rey carlos se dirigió a la catedral de
saint james en edimburgo para velar el
féretro de isabel segunda que será
trasladado a londres este martes
[Música]